today on the matt wall show goodyear was
exposed for its discriminatory policy
allowing black lives matter but not all
lives matter or blue lives matter uh the
media has rushed to the company's
defense but leaked audio now shows that
the policy is even worse than we thought
we'll talk about that and i'll play the
audio also five headlines including a
stirring speech from a pop star at the
dnc convention last night and in our
daily cancellation we'll discuss the
vile
left-wing mob that randomly destroyed a
man's life
because of an innocent typo in a tweet
all of that and a lot more on the way
pac show today but first i'm truly
excited to tell you about a new sponsor
on the show called charity mobile
honestly you know you couldn't ask for a
better transition here it really works
out because i think today especially
we're all thinking you know that we'd
like to find companies that support our
values well they are out there believe
it or not and when you find them you got
to support them we can't just see them
and say oh hey guys great thumbs up good
job but and then not support them no
it's up to us to support the companies
that support us and that's what charity
mobile is all about charity mobile
is the pro-life phone company five
percent of your monthly plan price goes
to the pro-life pro family charity of
your choice um that to me is is the
headline but there's a lot more to it
than that new activations and eligible
accounts get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping credit
check required restrictions apply on
that listen uh there are no contracts
there are no termination fees no risk
with a 30 day guarantee and you'll get
the live customer service based in the
usa as well to help you out if you need
it and i've dealt with these guys over
at charity mobile and they're great
really nice helpful uh living up to the
to the name i would say the way i look
at it is it's pretty simple
i love charity mobile because i'm
getting a great price i'm getting a
great deal i'm going to integrate great
service a great product but at the same
time i'm supporting a worthy cause the
most worthy cause the pro-life cost so
it's a win-win-win
all the way down the line so do yourself
a favor
and call charity mobile
at
1-877-474-3662 that's
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com
okay
after a leaked slide from an employee
training course at the goodyear topeka
plant went viral revealing a
discriminatory policy that allows black
lives matter and lgbt shirts and apparel
but not blue lives matter or all lives
matter
the media has been scrambling to come up
with some sort of excuse for their new
favorite tire company they're especially
determined to defend goodyear now that
president trump has stepped into the
fray to voice his
entirely justified objection to a
company that allows expressions of
support for a radical violent marxist
organization
but no expressions of support for law
enforcement
or even all lives in general
after supporting the boycott calls on
twitter trump was asked about it during
a press conference and here's how that
went mr president i want to ask you
about your tweet earlier today on
goodyear it was essentially calling for
a boycott on two year tires
do you want the federal government to
stop
buying and using goodyear product as
well and is there anything i'm not happy
with goodyear because what they're doing
is playing politics and the funny thing
is the people that work for goodyear i
can
guarantee you i poll very well with all
of those great workers in goodyear
and when they say that you can't have
blue lives matter you can't show a blue
line you can't wear a maga
hat
but you can have other things that are
marxist in nature
there's something wrong with the top of
goodyear
and what the
radical left does is they make it
impossible for people to do business
if they're
republican or if they're conservative
they put out all sorts of effort don't
shop there they do vicious things not so
different than what you saw on the
streets of portland two nights ago
boycott do you invest i don't know
that's up to people but i wouldn't
recommend it if they if they want a
whole
political speech if they want to let you
not do
what everybody's doing if they want to
wear
a maga hat or if they want to wear a
blue life you know what blue lives
matter right that's police men and women
uh that's a terrible thing that's a
terrible thing so they're using their
power over these people and these people
want to wear whatever it is that we're
talking about you know that now goodyear
has issued a clarification which
after sifting through the obfuscating
jargon is actually not a clarification
at all less is it an apology so here's
the statement in full i'm going to read
the entire thing to you uh just so you
know that i'm not trying to take stuff
out of context so bear with me this is
the entire statement from goodyear this
is what they have to say in their
defense and the media has uh has has you
know passed along the statement saying
that it sort of puts everything to rest
this is what they say yesterday goodyear
became the focus of a conversation that
created some misconceptions about our
policies and our company for those not
aware a widely circulated image sparked
a strong reaction and we wanted to take
the opportunity to provide some
important context to the visual and our
policies
they continue first the visual in
question was not created or distributed
by goodyear corporate notice the wording
there we'll get back to that nor was it
part of a diversity training course to
be clear on our long-standing corporate
policy goodyear has zero tolerance for
any form of harassment or discrimination
to enable a work environment free of
those we ask that associates refrain
from workplace expressions in support of
political campaigning
or any candidate or political party
apparently it doesn't include marxist
political organizations as well as
similar forms of advocacy that fall
outside the scope of racial justice and
equity issues
so those are the only issues you're
allowed to talk about but there's a
problem there which we will also get to
second they continue we appreciate the
diverse viewpoints of all of our more
than 60 000 associates which are at the
heart of many of the policies we
establish fostering an inclusive
respectful workplace is important to
establish teamwork and build culture
which is another reason we ask
associates not to engage in political
campaigning of any kind in the workplace
lessons for black lives matter that's me
talking about them for any candidate
candidate party or political
organization third and finally
goodyear has always wholeheartedly
supported both equality and law
enforcement and will continue to do so
these are not mutually exclusive i agree
you're the one goodyear who said that it
was
uh they continue we have heard that from
some of you that believe goodyear is
anti-police after reacting to the visual
nothing could be further from the truth
and we have the utmost appreciation for
the vital work police do on behalf of
our shared community
this can't be said strongly enough okay
so the slide was not created or
distributed by goodyear corporate and
it's not part of a diversity trading
class that is a far cry from denying
that it exists or that it accurately
reflects their policy the rest of the
statement would only seem to confirm in
so many words that employees are only
permitted to voice certain approved
views on certain approved issues now
audio from the training session at the
topeka plan has been leaked to wibw the
local news channel there in topeka
and this would seem to put all doubt to
rest
according to the audio employees are
instructed
that they may quote express their views
on social justice or or inequity or
equity issues such as black lives matter
lgbtq pride on their face covering
shirts or wristbands they are informed
that such expression is quote approved
and in accord with the quote zero
tolerance policy however
any associate who wears anything that
says quote all blue or white lives
matter
will be deemed as having acted
inappropriately all right here listen
listen for yourself
pride on their face covering shirts or
wristbands
that will be deemed approved
because it complies with zero tolerance
stand however if any associate wears
all
blue
white live matter shirts or face cutting
coverings that will be not appropriate
the unidentified speaker says the rules
were created to make a better work
environment
now around what you can wear
let's try to comply with these so that
way uh you know everybody feels good in
this this factory
i want to make sure guys think about
what we do in this factory right we all
work together to make tires that's what
we do that's what we get paid to do
so let's continue to do that and do the
right thing
keep this place uh what it's always been
a good place to work based on the policy
the the or based on the audio there the
policy is considerably worse than first
reported i doubt that it's illegal for
an employer to tell workers they may
express
pride in one race but not the other in
fact let me correct that i'm i'm i'm all
but certain that it's not legal this is
by definition racial discrimination and
racial discrimination in the workplace
is banned at every level of government
everywhere local state feds now
the the shameless hypocrites and media
who have previously claimed that cancel
culture is a myth
insists that those of us who object to
this grotesque explicit discrimination
are participating in cancel culture cnn
declared in an article that president
trump has embraced cancelled culture by
speaking out against goodyear msnbc
liked that talking point they adopted it
as well
in their headlines alleged news anchor
don lemon lashed out at trump calling
him the biggest snowflake of them all
and a hypocrite when it comes to cancer
culture and for good measure he's also a
bigot and a racist listen
we should point out the presidential
limo don is equipped with goodyear tires
and the company has a long-standing
relationship with the secret service and
the us military
what do you make of this call to
boycott a big american company well two
things the president is he likes to call
people snowflakes and names he's the
biggest snowflake of them all and we
should mention
i should mention he has criticized me
he's criticized you he's criticized my
colleagues he's called for the
cancellation
of cnn and he tried to get involved in
the att merger so he is a hypocrite when
it comes to cancer culture number two
it's because he is he's afraid anderson
that he is about to be canceled and
canceled by the voting public uh the
american people so i think listen
we shouldn't be surprised that this
president is a hypocrite we shouldn't be
surprised that he is making something
political that's not we shouldn't be
surprised that he's a bigot he's a bigot
he's a racist he's a hypocrite those
aren't opinions those are facts right
okay okay well don't worry you know a
news anchor can say all of that he
hasn't forfeited his objectivity because
we're informed these charges are not
opinions but rather facts well all right
then
it's all good
speaking of hypocrisy though
we don't need to strain very hard to
imagine
how the likes of cnn msnbc don lemon
everyone else on the left would react if
goodyear or any other company instituted
a policy in the reverse
if the rules allowed for all lives
matter
and blue lives matter but explicitly
banned black lives matter every single
person currently defending goodyear and
mocking us as snowflakes for criticizing
them would be convulsing with rage and
if i shudder to even imagine
goodyear had said that white lives
matter is acceptable and black lives
matter is not can you imagine all of
these same people will be accusing the
company of committing a hate crime and
calling for it to be disbanded by the
government and you know it and those
would be the most reasonable and
measured responses we can also assume
that a few good year locations would
right now be lying in smoldering ruins
and the looters would have a stash of
tires to go along with their burgeoning
collection of stolen shoes and purses
there is no denying this again we all
know how it would go
yet we're supposed to shrug at
discrimination in the other direction if
not applaud it
that is really the expectation
there is no real justification offered
for any of this no reason no defense at
least not a coherent or persuasive yet
one
it's just how it goes
yes you peon the rules say that certain
races can express pride others can't
certain races can announce that their
lives matter others can
anti-discrimination policies apply to
certain races not others racism is not
okay in one direction but it is in the
other you pee on you rub just accept it
we're told follow the rules
we can't explain them to you anyway
because you're too stupid to understand
just be a good boy and do as you're told
here's a pat on the head and and
goodyear is getting their pat on the
head for being a good little boy
for dutifully adopting racism and
calling it anti-racism for banning
diversity in the name of promoting
diversity for taking a position that
only a lunatic could really believe
namely that declaring allegiance with a
marxist political organization is
non-political while expressing support
for law enforcement or simply for life
universally is political
for that they get their pat on the head
and not much more because pat's on the
head don't equal customers in the door
and they've just sacrificed the latter
for the former
they're far from the first to make that
mistake and i'm sure they won't be the
last
look it's very simple for me
i am not going to play along with this
game
you want me to accept or pretend at
least to accept that all of this is okay
and understandable and somehow necessary
to heal racial wounds or whatever no
i won't you damned hypocrites you
absolute frauds you clowns
no
one rule
one standard for everyone
that's how i'm going to live
and the x and that's the expectation i
will have of everybody else
goodyear then is guilty of both racial
and ideological discrimination
and nothing will ever make that okay
it's that simple
let's go to five headlines
[Music]
let me tell you first about policy
genius before we get into five headlines
uh your your your loved ones you gotta
think about the situation they're gonna
be in if you happen to you know kick the
bucket croak as they say uh without
having life insurance think about the
situation they're going to be in with
everything going on right now a lot of
people are asking if it's even possible
to buy life insurance at all and the
answer is
yes it's still easy to shop for life
insurance not only can you do it it's
easy to do it if you have loved ones
depending on your income you probably
should get to that right now uh right
now you could save 1500 or more a year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies when you're shopping
for a policy that could last for a
decade or more uh those savings really
really start to add up what is policy
genius well it's an insurance
marketplace it's built and backed by a
team of industry experts and here's how
it works step one head to
policygenius.com in minutes you can work
out how much coverage you need step two
apply for your lowest price price step
three the policy genius will handle all
the paperwork and red tape from there so
really easy one two three uh on your
part you know on your end pulsar genius
is gonna do most of the work for you
policy genius works for you not the
insurance insurance company so if you
hit any speed bumps during the
application process they're gonna take
care of everything for you uh this is
this is the the time i think if you if
you have life insurance
on your to-do list cross it off take
care of it it won't take you long you're
gonna save a lot of money and you're
gonna be protecting your family so if
you need life insurance head to
policygenius.com right now to get
started you could save 1500 or more by
comparing quotes on their marketplace
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
all right um
let me go to my headlines if i can here
we go number one another night of the
dnc convention which which does come to
an end tonight and i'm
really excited to be hosting the watch
party uh for that tonight on all access
we'll we'll uh talk about that a little
bit more in fact i'll just tell you
right now all access live you can
you can sign up for that um it's our
most exclusive membership here over the
daily wires all access you go to
dailywire.com walsh right now get 20 off
all access with a coupon code access but
tonight at 8 45 pm we will be streaming
the um
last night of the dnc convention it's
gonna be a big watch party big
celebration
so we're celebrating that it's ending so
make sure to tune in for that anyway
last night obama spoke camilla harris
spoke and um a lot of people are talking
about those speeches for some reason
what those people don't realize
apparently is that all speeches from all
politicians are lame
and
uninteresting
like have you ever so any time there's a
political speech and people are reacting
to it in this big way
making a big deal of it as people are
with obama's speech you know
but have you ever in your life actually
and maybe there's something wrong with
me so i'm going to ask you have you ever
heard a a political speech
in which
something was said
that made you go
oh wow that's a great insight i never
thought of it like that in in your
entire life have you ever heard a
political speech that had a moment like
that
i never have and i've heard a lot of
them
i've heard non-politicians give talks
and speeches like that but i've never
heard that from a politician ever
so political political speeches are
always telling you everything you
already know
and want to hear or at least what one
side or the other wants to hear
but packaging it in a smoother and more
eloquent way which you know there's a
skill involved in that but but uh
there's there's just there's i the way
people react to political speeches
sometimes i think is there something
wrong with me that i don't see it cause
i listen to that and i say oh yeah well
just sounds like every other speech i've
ever heard from a politician nothing
special there
uh so we're gonna skip over most of that
but i wanna talk instead about the
biggest speech of the night
from a non-politician uh the mega star
i'm a huge fan myself billy eilash was
at the convention to perform and eyelash
despite being only 13 14 years old
decided to begin her performance with a
little political lecture for us which i
which this i i did hear quite a lot in
this that i thought was
valuable insight and here it is listen
you don't need me to tell you things are
a mess
donald trump is destroying our country
and everything we care about
we need leaders who will solve problems
like climate change and kovid not deny
them
leaders who will fight against systemic
racism and inequality and that starts by
voting for someone who understands how
much is at stake
someone who's building a team that
shares our values
it starts with voting against donald
trump and for joe biden
silence is not an option and we cannot
sit this one out
we all have to vote like our lives and
the world depend on it because they do
the only way to be certain of the future
is to make it ourselves
please register
please vote
yeah uh
really good stuff there is she standing
in a forest by the way like that's what
i couldn't the whole time i'm trying to
figure out it sounds like there's
crickets in the background
and she's in a like a foggy misty forest
they gave everybody else sound stages
and studios and they made her record in
a haunted forest that seems unsafe
frankly
is this the first address ever given
from a haunted forest at a political
convention that's what i want to know
that would be good trivia i think it
might be if i remember correctly though
we should note newt gingrich did deliver
some remarks from a serial killer's shed
during the 1992 republican convention so
similar kind of idea but this time
they're out in the forest
um
anyway that was that was good and really
i'm rethinking all of my positions now
after reflecting on what betsy irish had
to say there uh as i said big big fan of
her um
of her
music all right let's go to number two i
guess i lied so forgive me for that i
said i wouldn't play any of the
politician speeches on second thought i
will play just this one little snippet i
didn't completely lie i guess because i
said that speeches aren't interesting
they don't they don't
contain anything that i haven't heard
before which is absolutely true of this
but still it's notable so listen they
understand that in this democracy the
commander-in-chief
does not use the men and women of our
military who are willing to risk
everything to protect our nation
as political props to deploy against
peaceful protesters on our own soil yes
that would be barack obama former
president
supposedly above it all
not mean and nasty like old trump
the adult in the room right
yes that barack obama and he's making
excuses there for antifa
making excuses for rioters that have
left city blocks in ruins and killed
dozens of people calling them peaceful
that's what we get from
from obama who's just so above he
doesn't he doesn't do all the petty
politics
all he's doing is excusing this
dangerous group of people that have you
know
been killing and destroying for for
months now
number three speaking of making excuses
check out these tweets from a guy by the
name of andrew sampson
um he's uh in the tweet he's responding
to someone who says
that they were that their home was
broken into and andrew the compassionate
and empathetic man
says in response because bay area folks
refuse to pay taxes push homeless
shelters out of their neighborhoods
fight against social programs that help
the local populace suffering from
addiction and participate in
gentrification which is skyrocketing up
real estate prices that's the reason he
gives for the uh for the for the
for the break-in then he continues of
course there is the entitlement and
privilege that comes with all of that
someone breaking into your house should
make you question why they felt that was
their only choice and how the system
failed them
translation you have no right to be
upset if your home is broken into
uh it's partially your fault for living
in that neighborhood and also it's the
system's fault so it's your fault system
it's not the fault of the person who
chose to you know move their legs up to
your door open the the door or the
window or whatever and come in not their
fault it's everyone else's fault
now
if you don't want your home broken into
you're entitled
it's probably a good time now to mention
that andrew sampson is on the forbes 30
under 30 list meaning he's young and
rich
and now it's also also a good time to
mention that the vast majority of
break-ins obviously happen in low-income
areas not surprisingly in low-income
areas that's where many of the robbers
and burglars live
that's also where the easy targets are
working-class low-income households are
not going to have armed security
probably won't have cameras dogs they
might have one dog but you know they're
not going to have trained security dogs
and so on so
this rich sob
is sitting in his in his safe large
protected home
telling you that you're entitled if you
want to be as safe as him that's what's
going on here
and you see how this works this
compassion for criminals
is really just a total lack of
compassion for victims this is not this
is the absence of compassion
these are people who don't give a damn
about the victims of crime and they
package that sociopathic indifference
and selfishness in a nice little coding
of faux compassion for criminals uh last
note here
i don't know if you've ever suffered a
break-in before
my family has it was a long time ago i
don't remember it i was very young
i wasn't there at the time
but my mom was home when someone came
into the house
probably looking to steal something
presumably
i don't know if they actually did take
anything before running off but but but
here's the point nobody was physically
hurt
nothing of value as far as i know was
taken
and yet this is a highly traumatic
experience to have a stranger in your
home
violating your safety and security in
that way
to feel all of a sudden unsafe and
vulnerable in your own home
that's a terrifying experience it's not
a small thing okay it's not the kind of
thing
like if you wake up in the middle of the
night there's someone in your living
room that's not the kind of thing that
you just
oh you know hey the system failed it's
all right i'm gonna go back to bed hey
take what you want okay
you want you want a glass of water or
anything ain't no problem okay so sleep
on the couch
great
no you don't do that you that's that's
not the kind of thing you brush off and
andrew sampson wouldn't brush it off
either
that's the attitude he has for everyone
else he says shake it off rub some dirt
on it get over it you'll be fine
you're [ __ ]
and then he retreats behind his locked
gate with the motion activated cameras
that's the way it goes number four
reading from the daily wire sweden's top
infectious disease expert warns that
believing face mask will stem the spread
of covenanting is very dangerous
anders tegnel chief
epidemiologist at sweden's public health
agency basically the equivalent of u.s
dr anthony fauci an immunologist
says there's no proof masks actually
limit the spread of the virus this is
what he says uh it is very dangerous to
believe face masks would change the game
when it comes to coven 19. face mask can
be a complement to other things when
other things are safely in place but to
start with having face masks and then
think you can crowd your buses or your
shopping malls that's definitely a
mistake uh and then he goes on from
there like and this just this just shows
again how
there's an actual discussion to be had
here
about
the efficacy of face masks and how they
should be used whether they should be
used and who should be using them and
what context they should use this is
something we should really be talking
about but of course like with everything
else
once it is settled meaning that you know
the media and the elites have decided
that this is what it's going to be that
no more discussion is allowed number
five finally this is good stuff
jane lavender assistant editor for the
daily mirror
tweets an image a photo from a book
written in the 50s giving
women advice on how to get a man and i
thought you know in the 50s they really
got it they understood they did
especially on issues related to the
sexes
uh so so they they they understood so
i'm gonna go through this together we'll
all go through this together and um
we'll just see if you're a single woman
who
you know is looking for a man
then
i think this might be useful for you so
what we have here is one page i don't
know if she puts up no yeah it's just
the one page
and it's actually 129 ways to get a
husband
and here we have you know just uh
just you know 20 or 30 of them so let's
go through a few of them here okay says
number 14 be nice to everybody they may
have an eligible brother or son good
advice okay no problem there get a
government job overseas
i
you know these days i'm not so sure
about it i guess it depends on
i don't know if i would think of that as
a way to necessarily meet someone i
guess you could but it really depends on
where you are uh volunteer for jury duty
is jury duty really a place for that
kind of fraternizing i i i would like to
think that it isn't
um be friendly to ugly men
handsome is as handsome does good advice
tell your friends that you're interested
in getting married don't keep it a
secret yeah that's a big one tell
everybody uh write wear it on a shirt
you know maybe get a shirt made up
i'm interested in getting married
put up a billboard sign in in your in
your community with your face
i'm desperate to get married something
like that
that's gonna advertise and uh the
suitors are gonna show up to your door i
think maybe not to your door you
probably wouldn't want that but
i like this one get lost at football
games it's great i have been lost uh at
football games and
i didn't meet any eligible men i can i
could tell you when i was when i was
lost
mainly because i was ashamed that i was
lost at a football game don't take a job
in a in a company run largely by women
okay here's a good one all right now we
finally got down to business here so to
speak number 20 don't take a job in a
company run largely by women
uh
you might argue i'm not i'm not saying
that i'm saying this i'm not saying that
i'm not saying this either but
someone might say
that that is actually good advice in
general for everybody
across time and space some might say
that
i've heard some say that
some say it some don't say it that's all
get a job demonstrating fishing tackle
in a sporting goods store
demonstrating fishing tackle in a sporty
this is written by see at first i
thought
this has to be a list written by a man
based on the advice but this advice here
tells me this is a list written by a
woman because this is written by someone
who's never been in a sporting goods
store
i've been in many sporting goods store
in my time i've spent way too much time
and money in them in fact an
embarrassing amount of time and money uh
i've never seen someone there like
demonstrating the fishing tackle how
would you even do that are they gonna
have like a waiting a baby pool
and they're gonna have the jig on there
and they're they're casting in and i
what does that what would that even look
like
and frankly call me sexist uh if i was
asking for someone to demonstrate it i'd
prefer if it was a man demonstrating a
fishing tackle this kind of takes me
back i went to a cigar shop not long ago
and uh it was exactly
again many many cigar shops in my day
again an embarrassing amount of time and
money spent in them
first time in my life i've ever seen
a woman that was there in explaining all
the different cigars and which hey she
has every right to perfectly fine i'm
progressive so i i was fine with that
but there was a part of me
you know there was it was a part of me
taken aback by that's all i'm saying not
a negative way okay
so i'm thinking to be the same thing
with a woman demonstrating fishing
tackle so i don't know about this one
um let's see
oh there's anything there was a lot of
advice here we'll go through all of this
but carry a hat box
what how would that
help what is a hat box a box with a hat
i guess
see this is how
this is why i've got the the 75 iq
uh so you just carry a bat a
box with a hat around
is it a conversation starter like a
man's gotta walk up to you what you got
there oh a hat box
oh you got a hat box what do you keep in
that a hat
oh
well see you later see that's how i
would see that conversation going i
don't know if that's really gonna work
uh and then uh you know oh stand in a
corner and cry softly chances are good
that'll come over to find out what's
wrong
you know what that's that of all of this
that's probably the best advice on this
entire list
um
and not bad some good stuff there at
least it's it look some of this some of
it's antiquated
at least a lot of it is better than
probably the advice you get these days
uh you know
if you listen to a song like for example
[ __ ] you know
i think this advice is probably a little
bit more applicable in your everyday
life
though not much more okay let's go to
our daily cancellation now for our daily
cancellation today we're going to look
at a story that actually makes me angry
if you can believe it i know it doesn't
seem like me to be angry about something
but i am for a change of pace we're
going to be canceling the cancel mob
that came for a guy named john folk
last name spelled f-o-c-k-e i'm gonna
pronounce it folk because that's the
safest way to go i'm not actually sure
if that's the real pronunciation now
anyone inclined to believe the absurd
spin that as many left-leaning media
outlets have claimed cancel culture is
nothing but a myth concocted by bitter
conservatives
should consider the story of the
unfortunate john folk
the the announcer for the charlotte
hornets has seen his life torn to shreds
in the last few days
he's indefinitely suspended from his job
he's been condemned and ridiculed all
over social media major publications and
and national media personalities are
accusing him of bigotry and worse
all because
his thumbs
landed on the wrong letter while
composing a tweet
this was during a a game between the
denver nuggets and the utah jazz john
actually i'm going to call him john
we'll just go with john say first of all
john sent out a tweet about the action
on the court and the tweet said
shot making in the jazz nuggets game is
awesome murray and mitchell going back
and forth what a game
that was the tweet
only problem was the typo on the word
nuggets which
through two errant twitches of the
finger came out as the n-word
now john deleted the tweet fervently
apologized for it it was too late his
job was gone within hours there was near
unanimous agreement on social media
that either he wrote the n-word on
purpose
or his phone auto-corrected to that word
because he types it so often in text
messages and emails that it programmed
itself
headlines in publications like usa today
trumpeted the news you know a guy named
john folk tweeted a racial slur they
said espn personality mark jones
suggested that um his phone corrected
itself to the n-word because folk had
quote written it a ton of times and
trained it that way
and lengthy a lengthy yahoo news
editorial implied that john had
intentionally written it saying that the
claim of a typo quote strains credulity
and that the tweet signals that quote he
might have a problem with black people
so the scalp has been claimed a life
left in smoldering ruins and the
vengeful mob once again dances in
celebration around the ashes all because
of a typo
speaking of straining credulity
it is the absolute height of absurdity
to claim
that this man would intentionally tweet
the n-word
in some sort of maniacal act of
professional suicide the typo
explanation especially considering that
the r and t and u and i keys are right
next to each other on your phone's
keypad is significantly more plausible
than the self-immolation theory that
you're getting from the media the idea
that the phone had programmed itself
with a racial slur as an autocorrect is
similarly ridiculous as far as i'm aware
smartphones will will not auto-correct
to profanity unless you go into your
settings and specifically install those
words as options i sincerely doubt that
john an nba announcer who live tweets
nba games would have done that
is it really so impossible to believe
that this wasn't nothing but an innocent
mistake made by a man who was merely
trying to send an excited tweet about a
basketball game that he was watching
in the whole history
of people typing the word nuggets into
their smartphone
is it impossible to believe that
eventually by a roll of the dice someone
somewhere is going to make that mistake
no it's not not for any honest or
rational person anyway so why the
performative outrage
why the gleeful attempt to destroy the
life of some obscure
regional nba broadcaster nobody's ever
heard of well
because this is cancel culture it comes
in several different forms but here it
is at its most pernicious and loathsome
sure
sometimes the mob tries to cancel
high-profile people like jk rowling when
they voice a really objectionable
opinion like biological sex exists or
some other blasphemy
but it's especially toxic when it comes
for the obscure and the powerless and
devours them
for the sheer pleasure of the exercise
cancel culture is
by definition
petty cruel vindictive and arbitrary it
is also entirely false in its motives
and its claims the cancel culture mob is
never genuinely angry
never seeking real justice of course i
call it arbitrary but it's only
arbitrary in the sense that the penalty
bears no relation to the alleged
infraction the victims selected are not
arbitrary
john as a random white guy who committed
an accidental racial flub is the perfect
target
we know of course that if that if he was
non-white and had actually intentionally
tweeted slurs about white people and
admitted that it was intentional there
would be no mob coming for him at all
and he would still have his job
so the victim selection here is not
uh completely arbitrary but it is again
petty cruel vindictive and also
hypocritical of course it's funny that
the people who called for
this dude to be fired are largely the
same ones who'd insist that rioters and
looters and other violent criminals
should be given grace and patience and
their actions ought to be understood in
context burn a house down loot a store
assault a random pedestrian break into
someone's house like we just heard
that's deserving of our understanding
in that case we should consider the
overall context of of the actions but
accidentally hit the wrong keys with
your thumb
death penalty you're finished
that's how it goes
because it's all a game to these people
in fact i found it quite appropriate
that the first tweet i read when i typed
john folk's name into the twitter search
bar yesterday this was the first tweet
it said the john folk story is hilarious
fire that man
yes how hilarious fire him wreck his
life there's no reason to do it he
doesn't deserve it but hey it's kind of
funny if you're a sociopath
and you know what else is there to do on
a monday you might as well
so for that reason uh this particular
mob is yet again cancelled
and we'll leave it there today uh join
me again for the all all-access watch
party tonight dnc convention otherwise
i'll talk to you tomorrow have a great
day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
producer is austin stevens edited by
danny d'amico and our audio is mixed by
robin fenderson the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
president trump addresses q anon a new
york times editor doesn't even google
the man he smears and goodyear has a bad
day get it check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]
you